okay those who are joining us on the
live stream this is a internal design
review meeting looking at incremental
new features in Multan language okay so
what is the point here this is so this
is a suggestion of having a version of a
stream replace which is able to act only
on a subset of their of their characters
so so yeah it's a way of limiting the
area of action of the rules we don't
have anything like that forward and
replace exactly so in a sense in general
limiting in analytic expression would be
more difficult here the linearity of the
string helps young seems hard to justify
doing something like this I mean I would
seem to me that they a more general
thing which we haven't thought about and
haven't needed in 30 years is something
where you could say of a rule this is
you could give instead of a semi which
is a content-related you know this rule
applies only when you know aro B slash
70 whatever that's okay so that's a side
effect thing this would be a you know
restricting by content here and there
will be another thing which is applies
within or something like this a ro B and
then this gives some kind of criterion
for a part number criterion see what I'm
saying yes I mean that there's a similar
kind of thing that we've wanted for map
for a while which is to be able to say
map onto something with a restriction I
mean so right now the way that we're
restricting map is purely by level
number and so on right we could imagine
some much more elaborate restrictions
yes
so for example something that sometimes
it's needed is do not let replacement or
mapping functions enter this area that's
correct but you want to be able to say
that with the mapping function and not
you know um yes it could be an option
which is specifies the heads that
shouldn't be entered for example right
right that's a reasonable possibility um
so I mean here this is a completely
different thing that's that's reflecting
part numbers that should not be you know
I don't know I this does not strike me
as the most critical thing right now
this would be an interesting thing to
study this idea of the possibility of a
a function that describes its own domain
of applicability with an expression
right yeah that would be certainly
useful either either positionally or by
some ignore something option that says
do not enter here right um okay
all right that's gone I don't think
that's not gonna make it
new properly a nearest and take largest
yes so this is something I suggested by
imitating what entity value does which
is that it can't reproduce the entity in
the result by writing this property
entity yes so I find that quite useful
because it it avoids some thread in a
posteriori and things like that so I
wonder whether we should have something
similar in nearest and take largest with
a new property notation because you can
you can in the in the lists of results
we can put back the original point
oh by the way somebody on the livestream
is mentioning lenses from functional
programming not quite sure what that is
and anybody here happen to know about
those I don't know right now
well it's homework we can go find that
out um okay so what are you suggesting
here so this is part of yes so in this
nearest which what really works yeah
what do we write in the list of
properties that reproduce is the font
for the 4.6 in output I suicide okay
sometimes it's needed and if you have a
long list that we have to do threading
with the corresponding values you know I
agree I think it's useful um okay so
we've got element which is the element
index which is where that element is
distance so what are you proposing here
I see so you're proposing something like
source the source or origin but what are
the what are the functions which this is
relevant to so far these would be
nearest and take largest and and the
family so right now the the special
features are element index distance and
what are they for take largest I think
the same perhaps distance is not there
this has been increasingly added so it's
not even documented yet so Danny do you
remember which one I think it's
certainly index an element that's yeah
yeah no no it's not even documented yet
no so that's a third argument what are
we talking about here that's a third
argument for take largest no it's least
ro
properties the same as nearest I see I
see that original list arrow properties
exactly
so what is that you be asking to
reproduce in the take largest case at
the N or what in the nearest case what
you're asking to reproduce is the
original value is the target effectively
yes its sub sorry I didn't think but
enough yes no no this doesn't apply to
technologist doesn't seem to so take
larger if we ever do that
maybe I mean what about value for this
to represent that thing it's going to
get confused with element I think so I
mean I would actually have guessed the
other way around the element is the one
you're you're giving us input to test
against and the values are the ones that
are close so we would be reversing that
view well so ignant so are you saying
that then you would prefer input that's
not clear right now because they're both
inputs yes right
it can suggest it squirting or query
element it's not like it I don't like it
I think that's very specific to thinking
of this as a you know probing something
with that okay so let's just think again
how would we describe what this is
nearest looks at a list of elements and
finds the element that is nearest to a
given value that's the word we would use
you know there's a collection of
elements and we're asking what is
nearest to a given value I believe yeah
I was looking at the documentation we
always call it X so I think that's void
stay
there's always Assessor was what
abscissa sounds like some kind of you
know Conqueror from the Middle Ages or
something I think it was what abscissa
you can know with a evening the plural
it was this forward right okay III favor
value here but I would like to know
whether there any other functions which
we're going to do this with doesn't
nearest come in a family with some other
ones that we did this with already know
so far this extended notation with
properties is only nearest and
technologist family yeah what take
largest family I I mean take a smallest
take just sigh why are they
what are these accesses what how do
those appear in technologist because in
technologist you are interested in
getting the value and the position
simultaneously I see ok I favor calling
this value displacement no not so
complicated this is motivated by the
work on do trajectory so the idea here
is that given an in do path we want to
get the point which is like forty
percent throughout your path or
something like that so the suggestion I
have here is that we create this new
notation here a row Madrid to represent
the geo path from here to Madrid or the
displacements from here to the Madrid
what is geo displacement happen right
now
do these places right now takes either
two arguments to compute that thing and
having their here at Madrid or they
contain
is a list this this distance comma angle
so this is as many other geo functions
this is both a can constructor and a
container so this right now what this is
doing is it is if I'd say geo
displacement these no just so I
understand if I search your displacement
here more yes good things here is I
don't know what Thanks I've no idea
where things I am it's probably things I
mean you know but it would be wrong okay
yeah so that's second I see so that
canonicalize is to a distance in meters
correct and a bearing exactly okay so
what are you proposing now yes so the
idea is it's clearly in the next year
displacement input with at the end of
your page so the idea is saying in the
year displacement from here to Madrid
give me the displacement that would take
me to 2,000 miles so it's a way of
expressing intermediate points right to
throw you're saying your displacement
starts it doesn't specify where it
starts
once it has canonicalized so you can use
it in other fashion there is the
function geo destination the destination
takes the original point and the gear
displacement
sorry I'm confused here so Giro
displacement normally his enduro
destination you start at an initial
point and then you go a particular Giro
displacement as a generalization of go
at a certain bearing go it it's it's the
polar coordinates version is that right
yes correct okay so and the issue is if
you have specified two end points for
the Giro displacement this in this third
form right yes you want to say I don't
really want to go that far I want to go
in that direction but I don't want to go
that far okay so what you're proposing
here is that this format could represent
the angle I see that the angle could be
represented by thing arrow thing right
and that then the distance stays the
same stays in the same place exactly and
further down we can also say scaled of
0.5 and it's half distance from here to
Madrid okay it doesn't seem silly to me
now you're also proposing that there's a
pure thing which is the analog of lock
one lock - exactly
for consistency only but that's
certainly not needed yeah okay all right
it's just seemed reasonably reasonably
sensible I don't think I have a problem
with this what what else is that it
discussed about this no nothing I just
wanted you to see it and approve it and
then we can use the scale or with a list
etc so that we get many of those
intermediate points except because
Michael needs something like these for
their to specify intermediate points in
just a jacket or a six so wait a minute
scale will list inside it hey this is
going to be a list of all things Ogier
displacement is going to be is that a is
that syntax right now that's a accepted
so we can have a list bow in the first
argument or in the second argument
meaning displacements of these distances
for this angle or for these actually you
can have blissed smooth but so it's a
lot stability typing what they either
have to be I mean if they don't agree in
length that's gonna give an error that
correct no I mean that's that's like geo
position with a list of points it
represents a list of geo displacements
and that will represent 70 80 90
whatever it is yeah yeah right yes so
that's like a matrix of frontier
displacements now what am I gonna do
with this do you say destination here
with that and it gives you a matrix of
the positions so it's really the outer
product each other product exactly what
happened
try Geographics of point I think I think
Jonas protease perhaps not prepared to
handle Geographics of point and that
value okay but so there's a bug that
with respect to journalist blood yeah
that's a sushma issue
okay so I see so it's generating outer
product always in this case is that so
there's no list ability flooding it's a
pure out of permit yes yes all right
looks good to me
that was easy we move on yes okay so
these topic is a bit larger so we are
improving various things with order
functions so first of all there is this
issue we have discussed over times I
think of the f versus P function so f is
the function that we put in the second
argument of sort by and P is the
function the second function the
function that we play
in the second argument of sort and first
I wanted to ask you about names well
people can call these ordinal and
Cardinal don't they
sorting mmm I think's a function the P
function is a binary function the s
function is a unary function indeed yeah
so I mean I remember like from APL or
something they would say this notion
existed there and I think the point is
that maybe I'm wrong here but but you
know this idea that there's a there are
names for this in mathematics and
elsewhere I believe who knows them so
with respect to the P function I think
the correct names or their function we
call it ordering function typically
which is close yeah but the main issue I
see is that order capital order is an
order function but ordering is not an
ordering function that's the things I
find a bit confusing sorry again yes so
we have capital order and capital
ordering and when order is one of these
P functions but ordering is not so I
think it's a bit confusing when we say
ordering function because order in
capital ordering is not one of them oh
boy so order ring is asking for the
permutation which is the ordering of
this list excited okay but so what's
what's the question here so I mean we
don't have a good name to the buy
function exactly the main question is is
the name for the buy function and and
then the the other is a is somehow the
question of whether in the documentation
we should start moving from ordering
function to order function
I don't think so I don't think so or the
function is is I mean yes it might be
more mathy but I think it's totally
confusing okay I do agree we have always
called P or thing function yeah I think
it's the right thing to do I think it's
a common English usage I think order
function it's like you know the word
order is used in probably 25 different
ways in mathematics this being one of
them I said why you know why confuse
everything like that I see I see I see I
see Ubuntu feeding I'm pulling down a
copy of Ken Iverson's book from my shelf
to see what he calls um
serial sorting processors okay has a
whole chapter on sorting here I can put
this on my document camera just for fun
[Music]
works um okay just for fun we can we can
go look at what in the argh in ancient
times what was done yeah um I don't know
what this is this is some okay sorting
yeah I don't know I mean this is this is
definitely there's probably a vision
with us on the web somewhere but anyway
I I seem to remember that this exact
issue comes up here and I'm trying to
remember what whether there's a nice
name I mean not all the APL names like
the appeal notation can be quite crazy
right yeah yeah and this is crazy as
usual um I think this is not relevant
here alright nomatter not no no not
relevant this is the discussion of how
to do various kinds of sorts
which is not what we're talking about
here um anyway it's always fun when this
actually turns out to have something
relevant in it oh yeah
King that's right I mean that's the yeah
anyway and because that is what what
that is that's a that mathematically
it's some kind of ranking function I
think described is the urate the unary
case yes what do we call ordinal no no
what we call the unary by functions
define I mean in other words you give it
you say this is the rank of that thing
and then you sort it by rank so to speak
as opposed to a binary comparator
function means really our P functions
are comparator functions yes I think
what these really are a comparison and
ranking functions probably but that's
not what we what we're describing them
as I mean we could start describing that
p function as a comparison function yes
there were more accurate to say that
them to say an ordering function and
then the other one would be a ranking
function I believe those are two
possible names whether we want to start
changing to user I'm not sure let's take
a look at what you know what the actual
issues are here but we have added the
ordering or find some function to key
sort so we have feature eyes notes and I
think we should approve them seems
reasonable to me to have a comparison
function there yes
you know comparison function is the
right name for this I don't know what we
call it in sort right now let's take a
look
yeah I mean arguable that should be
comparison function I'm not sure anybody
else want to comment on this see this is
confusing because these are the return
values this is the comparison true/false
yes so so ordering or comparison
functions can be of two types they're
there
boolean ones and the numeric ones mm-hmm
and and the system supports both
simultaneously yes so the those that we
don't zero are more useful in
identifying ties because in a sense
true/false you need to evaluate them in
both orders to realize this is a tie oh
that's terrible yeah right so what do we
call that in in order to find by
applying okay yes that's another level
right it's got if F returns something
which itself is non-trivial to sort how
do we deal with that you see what I'm
saying
well sort by returns pass we've still
got to figure out how to order the pairs
yes and that's that's why we are working
on the third argument to sort by without
with an ordering function which has
always been missing and it's important
it's an important thing to have a
function which will be sort by which
handled simultaneously both types types
F and P functions I'm sorry
yes so what you were saying is that what
happens if sort by returns F values that
must be sorted yes that's correct
yes so the solution to that is adding a
P argument to sort by and we don't have
it yet but Danny will add that ok so
that plan is a third argument for sort
by that's right exactly yeah and that
that will be that will make sort by the
most powerful functional in the sorting
area because it can handle both at the
same time
this is knitting in applications like
for example sorting a bunch of vectors
by normal right this will do it always
via canonical order while typically we
needed a tremendous deja vu here this is
um we look at something I'm curious
whether well this is I have a very bad
feeling about this
this is my deja vu is I think in SMP it
had a sorting function that had exactly
this by two thing I wonder what they
were called
let me see um it's kind of depressing
this is like 38 years ago or something
um there we go sort what do you know
there it is
look this is okay so what this did
yields a list by sorting top-level entry
so that either what
the notion of a cardinal and I I knew I
remember this from somewhere have a
cardinal and ordinal sorting criterion I
see this is exactly our sort by right
yes we were discussing whether to add
the two arguments in salt or in short by
and it seems more yousafzai is a better
place to add them right and this is a
weird case here look of of doing a sort
yeah I mean sp4it sins did not have a
good pure function mechanism um okay I I
knew I'd seen this before right 38 years
ago or something um okay yeah so that's
an example of how we can use key sort
with poverty quarters looks good to me
or we could use numerical order six it
yep looks good yes well do you want to
up and feature ice the notes in the
patron so we can trust you to do that
okay okay so then we are working on
reversal by and here there is a small
issue but we want you to be aware of it
which is that when it comes to ties sort
and sort by do something slightly
different and now that we are
introducing the reverse sort and reverse
sort by we need to decide which one to
follow oh boy okay it is it's small
thing but but just for you to write okay
so what is happening here so thought
what is sort and sort by do for ties
exactly so when sort finds a time it
will use staple or fit so it will leave
things as they are
while sort by will go and use canonical
order in them so that's why even though
this plain to me why is there that
difference
because sorted says oh by numerical
order these two things are the same so
I'm going to leave them as they are
it could have say it could it could have
said oh I'm going to use canonical order
now because there was a tie I see we're
sort by is using canonical ordering of
the ranking function is that correct of
the original things before applying em
also if the ranking exactly if the
ranking is not able to decide because
they give it gives the same results then
it uses canonical why because it's how
it works no but I mean why do we make it
work that way rather than leaving it in
the same orders that came in adds I even
know I don't know this has been always
that way anybody know the answer to why
that was done that way I mean I don't
know why it was done that way right so
this is the thing that it has this list
of functions so if we wrap n in a list
then it will do that the opposite thing
so if some of the FE are the same then
the canonical order of the corresponding
e sub I are used exactly hmm but it then
has this multi criterion mechanism
exactly which lets you decide what to do
in case there are thighs so yes
if there's a singleton litter of F what
does it do because there is no other F
it uses staple order so if you run that
example on your left with n wrapped in a
list okay we'll do the opposite I think
one sorry I didn't understand that why
did that happen it is a different
convention with the least and without
the list okay Danny what we were going
to say one reason dot dot you actually
what I was gonna say what I think was
incorrect so okay so let's look at
reverse order then yes so reverse sort
follows sort and when it does it do the
reverse it doesn't do the reverse it
it uses table or this one so in other
words it leaves it the same if it if it
is a tie
and it seems reasonable that reverse
sort that's whatever sort does now the
prime is that reverse sort by cannot
follow simultaneously reverse sort and
sort by and that's why that's our
conflict I think it should follow so
that's what we have right now yeah I
think so it seems reasonable to me yeah
so then we have that identity there for
F subtlest I agree okay so another one
we
our debt which we have to ride a respect
for it is ordering by it has these four
arguments now oh my gosh okay what is
ordering by does ordering by doesn't
have any rough page not yet not yet
already which arguments does it need to
have so ordering by as minimal a has two
arguments right exactly it tries to
follows ordering which has three so
ordering by has one more a more than
three arguments are ordering it's the
least the number of results and the
ordinance unction the comparator
function the comparison function yeah so
somewhat bizarrely ordering by has a
ranking function and not next to it is
the comparison function yeah I think it
has to be that way unfortunately yes
Danny and I discuss that a lot because
there are several precedents and this is
the one that followed all of them but
yes it has FMP separate this F F is
compulsory
the other two are not looks okay to me
oh gosh how many functions we need here
well this one we don't have yet and I
just wanted to check whether it's worth
having in because we are there in all
this bias this one kind it's kind of a
gap no it's gonna be very confusing to
have that name each on your order by the
eyes of the kids hopeless I think it's
hopeless I mean if you don't like it
just just say order of f of X F of Y
right so this is an ik this is one of
these functions that can be used in
examples in relations to explain from
the point of view of one function what
the other does it's it's kind of a link
but these definitions I wrote there can
be added in examples and then people
would understand so I think that's fine
alright so ordering by can you guys
make some documentation for it it's on
my to-do list okay okay all right so
yeah so that's there we went quite
fastly right surprising okay that's okay
well we're at it let's just have a
little look at the longer list yeah
who has undone this whole semantics
cases business I don't think that's for
this meeting discuss that okay fine
um see what I have down on this list
here delete outliers that's again a
machine-learning discussion is that true
array Association what's happened to
that yes that that's that's with me I'm
but something I need to discuss
it's very ready to dataset so I'm
waiting for for severe to continue
working it's under has he been heard
from yes yes yes I'm having a meeting
with him later today
okay great okay so but but this this
idea of array Association of given a
collection of keys and an array
basically I mean I I think I mean the
name of Ray Association at least I
remember what it was when I saw it here
so the the basic idea is isn't from Tony
is an alternative way of representing
and nested list of associations
no no what this is is given an array
okay
like you've just got in a spreadsheet
but you want to label the rows by one
set of keys the columns by another set
of keys this sprays this turns your
plane array
into a nested Association collection yes
yes I was thinking of the other one
their association of Ray yeah sir what
is associational a as compared to a
reservation yes so so these discussion
came from a suggestion from Tony that we
could have an alternative way of
representing that nested list of
Association because the problem with the
nested list of associations is that it
needs to replicate again and again the
names of their I understand yeah what we
do actually in memory I'm not sure what
we're doing that do we have a packed
representation of this probably not no
no maybe it's the right thing to be
looking at it's a packed representation
where we don't have to reproduce those
things right exactly so that that's an
idea to implement at least part of data
set using that I've gotten better at
what I think is a better suggestion
which is we just haven't worked on
making you know we've got the
corresponds between data set and
external databases coming along but I
think a different issue it's just like
we have packed arrays yeah well I don't
have packed association arrays so to
speak see what I'm saying yeah yeah I
think that's the right way to go and I
think it would actually possible
conceivable at least that we could use
some of the packed array operators to
implement some of that stuff that's a
completely different group of people
that would be lob and people like that
yes it's some sort of multi-dimensional
Association concept yes exactly but
which which we already have I mean for
packed arrays we have multi-dimensional
pack to raise we just don't happen to
have multi-dimensional Association
labeled this is packed arrays I think
that's the right thing and that I agree
that that's a gap okay does anybody know
what's happened to find character
encoding switch my do you know yeah he's
working on information Tony hey
but I mean it do we know if it's
converging and what meeting is that
going to be good to get reviewed Andy
yeah I'm gonna wish is really other than
bring it up landing okay what happened
to column map and that whole family I'm
still thinking about it
and and I'm still concerned about having
to introduce very many functions so I it
would be better if we find some sort of
nice notation that we can place in the
second argument of third argument of map
for example something that perhaps you
can you know perhaps you can discuss it
again in some other meeting notes
existed I mean I kind of feel like
column map and so on it's a thing one's
ended up using a zillion times and it
seems like it's an easy-to-understand
thing and even if it's a you know a
synonym for something that has a more
structured form inside map it seems like
a reasonable thing to me I mean clearly
it is you know as it says that map at F
all come you know all come or two right
yes so the worries not so much about
column Matt but about having to
introduce column insert column delete
column extra column Exeter I mean if it
was just called Matt I mean these things
you know they're used so often in you
know I mean two-dimensional arrays look
the question is how specialist two
dimensions and if the answer is it's
fairly special then we should have these
and I think it is fairly special I mean
I think people you know we have a bunch
of functions that operate on
one-dimensional arrays in a special way
like insert for example so the question
is really if yeah I mean here's the real
basic question okay first question what
is the analog of ins in certain n
dimensions in sir
can insert at any position or any list
of positions so you're saying if I have
a four dimensional array that if I want
to introduce a new slab so to speak into
the four dimensional array for instance
a new two dimensional subspace into the
four dimensional array so to speak that
I can do that by defining but then in my
insert I have to actually give the
coordinates of every element in that
slab no time yes and the result perhaps
will be ragged now but but they did the
actual action is possible okay but by
explicitly giving it's not by giving the
it's by giving every individual sort of
elements in the slab it's not by
specifying the slab as a whole if both
things could be done because you can
insert a slab say at level two in a four
dimensional array so we are introducing
inserting many of them at the same time
okay how do you do that so so you say
let's imagine that I have a four
dimensional all right so let's say I
have a array three three three
let's just do three dimensional okay
yeah okay so there's my array yeah okay
so now I want to insert something at
what position so we can insert for
example another three by three matrix at
position one and then we will have
four by three by three result so you can
have that okay right
yeah and now I never remember what its
position object or object position yeah
element of your position so now right
there are three by three matrix
and at position one like that so that
was an insert at the top level okay so
now I want to insert it at a second
level how do I do that
at the second level you will have to
insert a vector for example so specific
insert no but I've got I've got this
matrix so how do I insert that see what
I'm trying to do I'm trying to say I
don't even know how to think about this
I see what to me I see what you mean yes
so in order to insert a matrix at the
second level we would have to insert
four vectors yeah all right or three
vectors at the corresponding positions
yes
so okay so the challenge here is can we
invent a version of insert that would
specify that what I want to do for
example if let's say I want to insert a
new column
I see column and every one of these
right well we have already the same
problem with a matrix how do we insert a
vector in a matrix because
see see to insert a role but not so easy
to insert I know insert is a level one
creature right I see column would be a
level two creature the question is what
is the generalization of that I see and
I think the generalization is that what
you're effectively doing is you're
inserting at a certain like like
something like this would be the the
three column and I mean you know talking
about this in a you know if this is to
mention one dimension to dimension three
okay so this is saying v three column so
to speak three column means the
dimension three analog of a column yep
yes indeed I don't know whether that
works actually but the notation should
be consistent we could insert the array
in your input 2003 or okhla one I don't
think that's gonna work
no so I think this is the challenge can
we generalize and it's a reasonable
challenge actually I think of our friend
Ken Iverson an APL did something like
this they call them AXYZ I think they
were incomprehensible to most people but
I think that they had a notion of this
kind of thing of how do you sort of
operate on an axis so to speak right so
really what this is is a level spec this
is something like a level spec well
there two things here there's a level
and there's a where are you in that
level kind of thing right so so they did
a third yes the third argument of an
insert like the delete or extract or
replace part our position specs and this
is something else we discuss in another
we need some sort of symbolic notation
for their position specs one of them
being column and then we said that right
so that's the idea that perhaps by
having this column we can have these
functions already acting on columns
without having to introduce column
dedicated functions or at least all of
them right a live stream is pointing out
tensor surgery functions and in neuron
that frameworks expand dims and stack
don't know exactly what those are
presumably I know on that folk would
would understand that and that is a good
question with respect to these things is
how this relates to the tensor surgery
that one wants to do for neural nets I
mean we may already find out that many
of our layer functions in neural nets
actually do precisely some of this kind
of surgery it could be so I mean let's
just take a look just as an example you
know things like I wonder what this does
reinterprets the input to be an array of
that dimension okay so reshapes its indc
this is equivalent of array reshape yes
I mean the idea is that these layers and
by the way that says you weren't
involved but that's a big designers
question is whether we're going to do
experimental eyes all these layers
whether we're going to commit to all of
these layers
um humph
well I think okay so what this has
turned into is a more general discussion
about about effectively array surgery
right which i think is great too topic
so I mean the question is what's the
analog what's the multi-dimensional log
of all these things
[Music]
okay they okay these operations
apparently I'm gonna paste from our chat
here the comment head so one of these
operations um takes this and inserts a
level I think we have a way to do that
up list to do it right and another is a
reduction operation no is a pairing
operation that takes okay that's a yet a
separate thing which is related to array
flatten right we yes this is like
matrices by blocks I think student yeah
so this is taking an outermost operation
binary operation here and threading that
through down into the lowest leaves of
the of the object yes I think we have
joined at a given level and the way I
would do this is just by wrapping our
list around those and then a
transposition you know I mean look the
basic meta point here is there is
potentially effectively a calculus of
you know a calculus of array operations
that might be worth us look because we
haven't really I mean the world of
neural nets okay so look two points to
make the column business we kind of have
known we need for a while it's been in a
standard package for 25 years it's
something one uses all the time the case
of higher dimensional arrays is somewhat
a new phenomenon I mean people have been
interested in that then the neural net
world
um and
then you know the question really is is
that a thing people really want to do or
is that a thing that's deep down in the
weeds and done you know one owner does
it once and it's not something for which
we need a general consumer eyes thing I
tend to think that it is useful to be
able to take I mean a very common cases
not very a common case is you've got a
bunch of matrices you happen to make a
list of those matrices you want to do
some operation on the matrices you know
which you could perfectly well do on to
individual matrices but you want to
immediately do it within these lists but
then we have map thread to do that yes I
mean part of this might be a you want to
get from here to there what functions
you're gonna use to do it and that's
more a user assistance question then it
is necessarily a we don't have the
functions question unless there's a
refactoring of our functions that would
make it easier to understand what's
going on um well we do have most of the
pressure and some of them are a bit
complicated I remember when I was
working on quantity array there was this
concept of threading the deepest levels
so our threading function threads
through there right to the most external
levels yeah I understand well that's
what this operation that we were talking
about just now this this um yeah the the
thing which takes an operation that is
at the top level big matrix you know
combined with big matrix or bigger a big
array big tends to combine the big
tensor and then takes that operation and
works it down to the leaves so to speak
yeah all right I think this is something
we could have a useful meeting about um
I mean I wish I had a real direction for
how to think about this um I mean I
think the first question is what are
some cases and we know the column map
and so on things are an example of that
that's a case where you know it's a very
common operation
and the question is so that's a unary
common operation right column map etc is
something where you're taking the tensor
and you're you know applying some
function to something okay so a binary
case would be you've taken two sensors
and you know back in the day there was
in ER and there was outer and those were
the things people cared about so at a
metal level when it comes to like the
neural net business why is it that
people now care about me because those
were the from a mathematical point of
view you know matrices as matrices and
so on or in general tensors well okay so
in ER and now we're gonna go general
relativity for a moment I mean you know
we have tensor indices and we have
contractions of tensor indices that's
what inner is kind of the special case
of a product of tensors with
contractions yeah yes the restriction is
that it takes only two and incomes it
contracts only one index of each one
right but in general we have tends to
contract right it does arbitrary that
given a single tensor does now I mean I
have no idea whether we've really
thought through
um
so tensor contract generalizes in ER in
the sense that it can do multiple
contractions at the same time and if we
have a tensor product in the first
argument it will handle several objects
now they they the thing that doesn't
have tensor contract with respect winner
is the ability of specifying the f and g
functions yeah because tensor contract
is fully dedicated to the algebra case
it's the same relation between tensor
product and outer outer specifies the F
function while does enhancer contract
allow an affronti function
it's just a matter of design it was
designed for the purely mathematical
linear algebra case I probably should
have enough energy function we could add
em in additional arguments yes right
I mean similar to the way distribute is
primarily designed for the algebraic
case but it can have arbitrary functions
in it too yes that's correct that's
correct
so tensor contract if I'm not mistaken
can do I mean a question and actually
it's a good question for the neuron that
folk whether cancer contract is relevant
for them and whether it in fact does
some of the things that some of the
layer operations do but okay but I mean
at a meta level one class of operations
on tensors is contraction yes in the
world of neural nets there may be some
new operations on tensors that people
start caring about I mean contraction is
very much a creature of the kind of
linearity you know tensors as some kind
of linear operator type things isn't
that right you know indeed for example
one and another restriction in terms of
contract is that contractions are always
of two indices we could think of
contractions of multiple indices right
the concept that yeah that doesn't have
a meaning a linear enter
right well we're effectively you're just
feeding those indices into some
arbitrary F function right what is the
most general form of ten second so the
most general form how does okay so
there's transit there's transpose in
which again can take to transpose is
moving around indices contract is taking
indices and doing reduction across those
indices correct yes so the three
fundamental operations with arrays in
terms of which you can write most of the
other ones or all of the other ones in
linear algebra are outer products
contractions and transpositions but then
if we go out of linear algebra we have
more operations like array of reshaping
that never happens in linear because
linear algebra dimensions are always
preserved yes so there are a few more
operations that do not have a direct
linear algebra meaning but they are
operations container of race seems to me
we should explore this yes so the fully
general linear algebra case I have under
control and and have some functions
there is in internal contexts which
generalize the concept of our
reconstruction we can discuss about that
all right
let's let's try to get I I was not
expecting this particular spin-off
meeting but let's try to get a meeting
with you guys probably with I mean I
think Rob is relevant to the stuff also
ambered the neuron that folk to talk
about general array operations and see
and the main result there is I want to
determine whether we're actually going
to put in column map and so on my guess
is that the answer will be that we will
want to do that but that it will be a
special case of some things and you know
the suggestion then is that there may be
some more general array operations that
could be the master array operations
that we need and then we need to
understand how those relate to the
neural net layers and the particular
operations like the flattening layers
and catenation layer layers and so on
and whether there is a much more general
way to represent that stuff which may or
may not again be something we actually
want to you know it may still be very
useful to have the layers exactly as
we've set them out because that's
something you can easily read so to
speak and not the most general case all
right we should wrap here um ok we got
through our agenda which is good thanks
everybody thanks to folks on the
livestream lots of great suggestions
here um talk to you all soon